jornadas de protestas en el continente
americano en perú se agudiza la crisis
miles de personas salieron a las calles
de lima a la capital para exigir la
renuncia del presidente pedro castillo
disposición para que pueda entrar una
persona que realmente corresponde al
carga el aumento de los precios de los
combustibles y de los fertilizantes fue
el catalizador de las manifestaciones de
los últimos días por otro lado en brasil
y en medio de un contexto preelectoral
manifestantes se posicionaron en contra
del mandatario jair bolsonaro la ciudad
de sao paulo fue testigo del rechazo al
aumento de los precios de los
carburantes el desempleo y el hambre
esperamos que esta presidencia cambie
que nuestro presidente lula regrese
porque creemos que respalden a los
trabajadores y al pueblo y no solo
gobierne para la élite
brasilia sede del poder ejecutivo se
sumaron a la protesta varios
representantes de los pueblos indígenas
en chile decenas de personas se
manifestaron contra la nueva
constitución los asistentes mostraron su
desaprobación porque según los
demandantes la nueva carta magna excluye
derechos ya consolidados en esa nación
como la propiedad privada o la
expropiación del fondo privado de
pensiones de mentir
aquí en este país se tiene que hacer
entre todos y tenemos que mejorarlo
entre todos yo no voy a aprobar la
constitución refundacional de una
constitución
la convención constitucional llegó de la
mano de las violentas protestas que
paralizaron a la nación en el año 2019
en las que se exigía entre otras
cuestiones la eliminación de la carta
vigente heredada de la dictadura de
augusto pinochet